i'm thomas wiki and
the first thing i want to announce which
we're all very excited about is that
pimc 4.0 if you don't know what prime c
is you've come to the right talk this is
what i'm going to be talking about but
the new major release is now finally out
and uh yeah it's amazing it has a new
jax back end
for faster sampling it has gpu support
and it used to be based on thiano which
was discontinued it's like basically a
tensor framework before tensorflow was
cool
tensorflow and cool anymore before
tensorflow jacks was cool
but now it's based on
zara
and it has a whole bunch of other cool
stuff so that's what i'm going to be
talking about
but more from an applied business sense
and i remember when i was in grad school
and fell in love with bayesian modeling
i always had this
thought of like well how is it being
used in business is it even being used
in business
and
that
there was very little information on
that out there so in a way i made this
talk for myself just
eight years ago
to basically show
how business is using primacy modeling
the experience
i have now is from pi mclabs which is
our bayesian consultancy
and
basically we're a team out of the core
developers of pimc and we just banned it
together and now started to work on
consulting projects helping startups to
fortune 500 companies solve
hard data science problems using basic
modeling
and
when i recently thought about like well
where have we made the biggest impact
mainly actually two domains uh are most
active in base and modeling it seems one
is life sciences
where we consult with companies like
roche indigo but also marketing uh and
that was more of a surprise to me just
because well life sciences make sense
it's very close to the
uh to to science right and basic
modeling has always been more
established in academia
but
marketing uh i didn't know much about
but like just all these marketing
companies basically were writing us and
wanting support
and help building their various models
and
in this talk what i'm going to do is
basically use marketing as the example
case study for
how the benefits of bayes and modeling
are particularly
impactful there and why they haven't
adopted it so much
so yeah why specifically marketing
to set the stage there's i think a
couple of trends that support this but
really i think a lot of these reasons
are transferable to many industries
like most of them they're very
quantitative by now right like the data
science approach there is fully
present
and
but there are also some other things
like for example in general the internet
right everyone's becoming more privacy
conscious so
these third
third-party tracking cookies by now are
basically going away
it's called the death of the cookie so
it's just very hard to track people
online these days which i guess is a
good thing but hard if you want to track
people online and know where marketing
dollars are going so it makes it very
hard for marketers to actually
know
whether what they're spending on certain
platforms is effective or not or how
effective it is and that's the problem
that we're going to look at
and then the third one is in-house so it
makes sense that they're adopting open
source tools like pymc
so the thesis that i'm going to put
forward is that basic modeling is the
perfect tool to address these and more
challenges
and we're going to look at probably the
prime example of marketing which is
estimating marketing effectiveness so
how effective are my marketing channels
and
towards this we're gonna use just very
very simple simulated data
where over time now i have
two time series i have
how much i spend
in thousands of dollars
and how many new customers i got right
so obviously that's the whole point of
marketing is to sell more products or
get more marketing and
to get more users
and here you can see this effect that
like well if we spend a lot of money we
get a lot of new users if we drop our
marketing spend we just get very few
users right so
very simple
and we're going to do some simplifying
assumptions which we then later on will
review but basically this first section
of the talk is just to build intuitions
about what bayesian modeling even is and
how to think about it and then really
take it further than that and show
more advanced case studies but here
we're gonna start very simple
and gonna care about just uh assume that
we just have a single channel here right
so let's say it's all just google ads
right usually you would have facebook
ads and everything but here it's just
well we're spending marketing dollars on
this one thing and we're getting new
users
and the central thing that we're
interested in is our customer
acquisition cost the cac and i'm going
to be using this a lot so remember what
the cac is it is how many marketing
dollars do you have to spend to get one
new customer right so that's in general
what we care about
and
the other thing which we care about of
course is
how much
we gain from a user so how much does it
cost me to get one and how much do i
earn in terms of the whole lifetime that
they're with me
which is the customer lifetime value and
we're going to assume that that is also
just a made-up number it's usually quite
a bit lower than that
we're going to assume that that is 630
on average and of course then the
question is well do i have to spend more
in marketing than i get from that
customer so this is basically that
threshold that we want to cross
and
well if we're very naive about this you
might think well actually this is a
super simple problem right so here now
i'm just plotting this data differently
so i'm ignoring the time domain and i'm
just saying okay this is how much i
spend on ads and this is how many new
customers i got and of course we see
well it's
clearly correlated right the more i
spend the more new customers i get
and maybe if i take off my glasses
we might think okay well this is like
linear ish
maybe not but for now we're going to
fit a linear regression to this right
this is what statisticians do
and
if we do that then actually the the cac
the customer acquisition cost just falls
out of it
right so the the slope of this is i move
one
point here and then x points here
but i want the inverse of that i want to
know well if i move one point here how
much do i have to spend for one new user
right that's the cac so it's one over
the slope it's the inverse and if i do
that right it's just a single line and
whatever stats package you want and the
result is
647.97 precisely all right so amazing
with statistics we get
very precise answers
and
that means it's a bad channel because
well we had we assumed that we had to
spend 630 well that we earned 630 from
this right
so now maybe some of you in the audience
are like well
not so fast thomas um
there are a couple of problems with this
and i fully admit to that um
one of the problems is well
this line could be a good fit right but
what about this line
or
these lines right they're all i don't
know sort of go through that point cloud
and and
how plausible are they are they also
plausible and maybe i take maybe i'm i'm
trying to be good based in and i'm
taking this to
the marketing team and i'm saying like
okay well these are all different values
that could work here and
then the market team actually told me
well
even without like knowing anything about
this data i already know that like
959 like this value in red is like
completely impossible like no marketing
channel is ever going to be that
ineffective right
so ahead of time we can rule this value
out but with just running linear
regression if that is the best answer
that's provided well that is still the
answer i'm going to get right so in this
simplified framework i don't have a way
of excluding certain things that are
nowhere completely ridiculous
so three things are missing from this uh
the uncertainty right which i showed is
well we don't just want that single line
which gives me like this super precise
answer we want to have some sense of
like well are other fits plausible and
how plausible are they
the other thing which we saw is that we
can't include any domain knowledge that
anything say above 900 is just
completely unreasonable and don't even
need to consider it
and then of course
now that i have my glasses back on this
is uh not linear right so there's
definitely some saturation and this is
very common what you see in marketing is
just like showing someone the same ad 10
times it's not going to be twice as
effective as showing it five times right
there's a saturation effect where it's
just yeah the message just stops sort of
carrying through
and this is a big problem and this is
why also you're not just usually using a
single channel but many channels
and uh yeah so those are all drawbacks i
guess and now we want to solve them and
well how do we solve them
this is where
our friend
the reverend
comes in
he had this whole thing figured out
hundreds of years ago actually it's not
just uh
thomas base but it's
laplace
who we have to thank for this but
history can be cruel sometimes
but anyway so base it is um and i like
to introduce that by just some
comparison with some techniques which
some people here might be more familiar
with which is that of machine learning
or i'm going to narrow it down to black
box machine learning where we have some
data
we pump that into a classifier we have
data which is like features and labels
right
classifier and outcomes predictions and
cool
that works right
actually boosts really powerful tools so
i could learn
but if
and if we only care about that then
that's totally fine we only care about
prediction but maybe we care also about
understanding something in our data
right like maybe we have some knowledge
about the causal structure of how my
data was generated that i can't really
incorporate here right so it's purely
data driven and i can't really yeah
do any inference with this
and
well the nature that it's black box
means i can't look inside right so
anything that classifier learns it can't
really communicate to me and explain to
me what it has learned right so that
that learning is just happening in there
in some crazy
high dimensional space um and yeah i
can't
i can't look at it
and then
well as i mentioned
it's very automatic which is cool but
the downside is well if you have
information that you incorporate that is
very difficult so it's just data driven
now contrasting that with basic modeling
which i hear as an open box or
transparent transparent box
here
of course we also start with data but we
then build a
excuse me
uh custom base in model and outcome not
predictions but probability so the whole
thing is incorporated in probabilities
and well it's transparent right so the
model that i built is custom
and it's in computer code and i just can
look at it and and investigate and
really and communicate it to other
people that is really important
it's composable meaning i just assemble
a model out of very simple building
blocks it's basically the lego approach
to doing statistical modeling where we
just have these individual probability
distributions we plug them into each
other and we can that way build very
flexible models on all kinds of
different things
and it has the ability to um work in a
more called way right so if i know how
my data was generated i know something
about the uh generative process i just
incorporate that that that basically
becomes my model so it's a general
framework
and this is for me just a very intuitive
way of thinking about my data science
problem right it's like well how was my
data generated and that's just how i'm
going to build my model
and as i said the whole thing is
probabilistic
which for me is probably the best way of
expressing
um yeah uncertainty and and things like
that right so everything we do will
always have probabilities associated
with it so we're not just getting point
estimates um like that single linear
line but we're actually getting a whole
probability distribution of things
but for me actually my favorite part of
this is that
it's very code friendly so
it used to be back in the days of of
base and later uh that
you just had this very simple formula of
base formula uh but it actually was not
already useful because you couldn't
really solve it right if you just like
tried to work out the math it just
became really really ugly chris was just
mentioning that on his in his tutorial
and
fortunately though now we have very
powerful approximation algorithms and
this these make this very powerful
especially if you combine it then with a
language that allows you to
define these models in computer code so
for me
with computer science background and our
statistics background and math
background this is the way that i like
to do statistics right is it's not just
on a blackboard but rather in jupyter
notebook coding a model
i find a problem with it i iteratively
improve it just like i would with code
so that that for me is like my
the superpower for me
so from a high level and uh basically
this is uh so the the um still in the
building intuitions part we're gonna
take it up a notch soon
so we start out with
solution proposals so as i said before
right we can communicate with the
marketing department they tell us well
certain
values uh are just completely
implausible right so they might tell us
well custom acquisition costs over 900
are impossible so when i define my space
of solutions to this problem which are
the tags right the thing that i'm
interested in
i can already exclude that here
so that's the first thing right that we
wanted to be able to do
and this is where we can include domain
knowledge and then we build the model
and as i said it's generative and i
basically this is i can incorporate
various model structures so this is
where i really say okay well this is
what my data was generated let me now
build
a graph representation of that that maps
it and that i incorporate in
in the framework
then i evaluate whether that's
whether these solutions right that i'm
taking from here plugging into the model
and then evaluating on the data that
gives me the answer is that now a
plausible solution or not right so
either it's a good fit or it's a
terrible fit like this line would be
and then if i just keep doing that over
and over and this is where the mcmc
sampler comes in that is doing the
inference so this is just being run in a
loop and it gives me then
the collection of plausible values
that all do a good job of explaining the
data that i've seen so all these
different cac values here right there's
this histogram over a thousand potential
values that the customer acquisition
cost could reasonably be given the data
i have
and
the main thing to note of course is this
is not a point estimate right so before
what we started with was just like oh
it's basically yeah um 647.98
uh and now it's well it could be
anything from 600 to
500 to
680. or up until 700 and this is a scale
on the y
on the y axis
so
that's the high level idea but i also
also mentioned well
the super power if you remember is that
we can do that in code so rather than
having the model in just
statistical speak we just write it down
in computer code
and yeah that's very susceptible to the
iterative workflow
now let's start looking at the solution
proposals
this is what bayesians like to call
priors i'm not a particular big fan of
these more traditional terms so that's
why i'm using different ones but
yeah so priors specify my belief in
different values of the custom
acquisition cost right so these are all
potential values that the customer
acquisition cost could be without having
seen any data
and i'm assigning a probability here
using a probability distribution
and this is the one that i came up with
right so it says everything under 900 is
just very implausible but and everything
below
well zero is also very implausible
now let's look at the code
i hope this won't be
too scary if you haven't seen this don't
worry too much about it i'm going to go
a little bit quicker but at least i
wanted to give you a flavor so that you
have an intuition for how this roughly
looks like right so
don't worry too much
so
the first line is just boilerplate we're
setting up a new model with
pi mc so pm imported as pymc
and the first two lines are the
parameters of a model
really so far it's just a linear
regression model so it has an intercept
which i call baseline and it has the
slope which is the cac
but i don't just specify these
parameters are also assigned priors to
them right so the plausible space that i
just mentioned before
and the first and this is a normal
distribution that i'm going to assign
here these are these two
and i give it a name i give it a mean
and a standard deviation and this just
basically incorporates my knowledge
without having seen any data
now that i have the parameters i
i combine them
in my linear regression formula right so
intercept plus
the data this is a numpy array of
this
these values on the x-axis times 1 over
the slope right if you remember cac was
the inverse so i'm just doing that here
i have a parameter for the variance in
my data the epsilon
the noise that's a half normal which is
a normal distribution that's chopped up
at zero because variances can only be
positive so this and this is trivial
prior information that i always have
right so certain things just are natural
laws that i'm incorporating here
and then finally
i have to specify how that relates to my
data and this is where
this is called the likelihood and i pass
in my predictions that come from this
right here
my estimation noise and then the data
that i've observed which is the number
of customers so my y value is here so x
trans the x values transform via this
formula
give rise to the
y values that i'm plotting here so
nothing magical right parameters
linear regression data
and the coolest thing is
i don't have to do any math right so i
usually the math behind this model um
might be quite complex in this case it's
simple but if you just would build this
up as we're gonna do then this would be
really gnarly and nonetheless it doesn't
matter what you write up here to an
extent
you just call what i like to call the
inference button
pm.sample and it'll just basically do
that thing for you which i described to
you here
of running this loop and giving you this
distribution of my plausible values the
thing that i'm interested in right the
posterior
and well this is what it looks like and
this is basically it right so then we're
done we just run the sampler we build a
model we run the sampler and we
investigate the results and this is the
answer we get and i already said well
this is nice because it has this
uncertainty in what plausible values
could be
but rather than just looking at it it's
really useful and here we can also
contrast this now with frequency
statistics where maybe the thing if you
remember from before the customer
lifetime value we wanted to test was the
cac higher how do i have to spend more
than i get from getting a customer
and
uh well if we were to do this in a
frequency framework we would have to
like find a specific test for that right
someone would have to derive already the
right test for doing this
and
that is another cool feature about basic
modeling is that these tests basically
just are free right so once you have
this posterior you can just investigate
this however you like so to answer our
question
of um
whether it's below 6.3 well we just
count how many values are below 0.63 so
you have to multiply by 100 i apologize
for that so 630 was the value right
which translates to 0.63 here but it
doesn't matter because all we're doing
is really just slicing that posterior
upon that value which we care about and
can now say okay which how much how many
of those values what percentage of
values below that and
the thing that comes out when i do this
is a probabilistic answer which is
25 probability that this channel is
profitable
and that's
that's simple and awesome right because
that you can just take to someone and
say okay well this is this is the answer
basically that you're looking for if you
want to invest invest in this channel
this is the risk that you're taking on
and
well in business we're always taking
real world decisions and
so if so having that sense of
uncertainty excessive probabilities is
really really important so that you know
how what kind of risk you're taking on
so as drake would say
forget about point estimates use
distributional estimates
exactly
so that was the intro now we're going to
crank it up a little bit um
and talk about improving the model and
this is work that we did at pimec labs
together with hellofresh these are the
people involved
where they started out with a simple a
model that was a little bit more complex
than that
and there were a couple of improvements
that we did and one of the first things
which is quite simple if you remember
right that was not linear that data
so well one easy thing to do is to then
use a nonlinear decay function so this
is called a reach function here and well
it works like you can see here
and if i do this in gray now you can see
the model fit
it fits the data perfectly well because
that's the way i generated it
but
but the point here is that uh i i'm not
showing the code but trust me that it's
just a very simple three-line code
change right so in terms of this
iterative
process um i see oh this is actually a
terrible fit now i do this change now
it's a better fit and now i can just
keep improving it just with simple code
changes
well the other thing as i mentioned
before is we made that simplifying
assumption that we only have this one
channel in reality we have many of them
and
now you might say well that's simple i
just build uh instead of linear
regression multivariate linear
regression and i just include many
different channels and this is
essentially what you end up doing is you
have a separate parameter which tracks
the custom acquisition cost per channel
for each channel's data
and you do that k times if you have k
number of channels
and that's fine you can do that
but
what if
you do that and this is what it looks
like so let's say we have now several
posteriors the plausible values that
look like this for different channels
and one of them is just all the way over
here
and maybe this is also one where you
don't have tons of data for
so do you really believe that well
they're all over here and this one just
is basically an outlier right so
the model itself can't incorporate that
right because there's no relationship
between these parameters they're all
estimated independently
and this is what allows for something
like this to happen however if we apply
a really cool trick we can turn this
into hierarchical model where we say
actually i have some information about
these individual parameters in that they
come from a global
overarching distribution
and
how to think about that is while we have
a distribution here
and
these points are the means of the
distributions and this is the group
distribution that i'm assuming and if i
assume this group distribution right
that they all follow normal distribution
these ones down here then this mean is
very very unlikely right
because it's all the way over here and
what the model will do in response so
this is not the actual fit this is what
the model would say if i were to propose
this
but if i were to estimate this it would
pull this estimate in because it would
say okay well actually i know more about
this distribution this sharing of
information between things
and these hierarchical models are
extremely powerful and
wherever you have nested data right the
pattern we see this pattern all the time
but it's very rarely actually
facilitated in the modeling process so
yeah
especially if you have wide data where
you don't have a lot of data per class
this is something to really look into
and actually directly after this
hannah has given a talk in room three
about this type of modeling so
definitely check that out
another thing we can do is well now we
have uh
assumed so far that the customer
acquisition cost is constant over time
right so the first thing i did when i
changed from the time series plot to the
other one was to throw away the time
dimension
is that really plausible that um i don't
know during covet marketing was as
effective as pre-covet probably not
right things change the world is
changing all the time
and
what we did for that model then was to
say well instead of assuming that it's
constant we can allow it to vary over
time and
model this for those of you who know
more about this using gaussian processes
which are time varying processes time
varying time series processes that allow
basically for rather than just constant
over time each channel now has some
pattern
and that's neat we can estimate this
it's actually really hard because now we
have
for every before we just had
a handful of parameters right for every
channel we had one and then the noise
now we have all of a sudden like blue
blown up the complexity of this model
tremendously we have uh for every time
point for our channel a new parameter
right that's following this very complex
structure
due to the process that the
gaussian process that we facilitated
here
and when we first did that it actually
didn't work it didn't converge
because there's not enough information
to really
estimate this over time
but
if we
combine this now with the previous idea
right of a hierarchical model
we can sort of assume the same thing
here so during cobit
yes the marketing changed but probably
it changed across all these channels
right like they were all impacted in a
similar way
so we can say okay well let's combine
this idea
with this idea and build basically a
hierarchical time varying process so
uh yeah we and we can't just do that
right we write it down um now we have
this global time varying process over
arching this which like will
drop everything down during covet and
but still allow for individual variation
right so it's not that they're all the
same they can deviate
but this will
regularize this
really that's all this is it's like very
fancy regularization and
um uh and this is what made the model
work then right so it's and it's kind of
maybe counter-intuitive that we add like
all this super crazy structure to it and
now it's actually working but what we're
doing is we're constraining the model um
and and giving it less degrees of
freedom more parameters but less degrees
of freedom and that allows it to
estimate it even if you don't have a ton
of data
because really what we're doing is we're
injecting more prior information into
this
and
yeah so
this is the joke from
spinal tap where we're really turning
things up to 11
because the model by now is like insane
right it has like
tens of thousands of parameters
this super crazy structure but again i
just call pm.sample the inference button
and it
it just works and
it takes um i think
20 minutes to estimate so this is i
guess another thing uh the message i
want to send out is these tools used to
be more for toy models but by now with
sampling on the gpu and stuff like that
they really allow to build
complex large scale
models that scale
so it's not a toy anymore
and just to show you that i'm not just
making this up this is based on real
world data
from hellofresh these are all the
different marketing channels and you can
see yeah so there is definitely some
variability some of them look quite
different this very choppy one is one
that is like very saturated which leads
to this weird looking effect but yeah so
so this is basically the inside and of
course because we're good proper
bayesians we have uncertainty estimates
around these lines as well
we have
um
[Music]
tested this model so basically these
models are called bayesian media mix
models
and they're quite popular in marketing
and
ours is not the only one there are a
couple of other ones
which we decided to compare it against
so there's the google one
they have also a package for that
there's an uber just came out with a
paper where they also have timering
components so we compared this on
hell.data and
so here lower is better here higher is
better and i'm very
happy to say uh that that our model is
the best
otherwise i probably wouldn't show that
graph
another thing that is often being done
um or that
well that actually has a very high
practical business
application is that uh is a what-if
scenario analysis so
badly the the marketing team at hello
fresh is really excited about this
because it really it matches the way
that they think so here they can now go
in and inquire in the model certain
things right so for example what happens
to my expected new users over the next
month if i were to drop my marketing
spend to zero or i have it or i believe
it is or i double it
and we can forecast all these different
ones and then they can make informed
decisions on the model and they
yeah so it's it's really uh facilitating
their decision making
and uh well a couple of things to note
of course we get um
uncertainty in our forecast but also
it's not just a flat line we get
things like seasonality included as well
the final point i want to make is that
something that's very powerful often
especially if you have work in this
regime where maybe you have
a lot of data but not a lot of
information is adding other data sources
that are related to this and adjacent so
you can just yeah build a more complex
model that says well i actually know
something more about the customer
acquisition cost for example in this
case they're in these lift tests which
are essentially a b tests
but they're very expensive so you only
run them very infrequently so this is
what happens here on these points and
you can put that into the model and say
well actually here i ran this lift test
and this is what it said and it will use
that to
inform the other estimates as well but
they also voucher redemption so i
include that
and actually in their case there's this
like
internal political debate going on
between oh like vouchers give us much
better information and other people say
like no it should be just the marketing
spend
so why not do both
and yeah but this can be done of course
in in many different
scenarios as well
so
when does uh basic modeling work best
to to summarize this
whenever you don't have a simple
prediction problem you want to learn
something about your data you want to
gain insight into your data
and you have structured data like maybe
you have nested hierarchical structure
in there you have time series
some causalness that you know something
about
allows it to integrate domain knowledge
and
when you're making real world decisions
uncertainty often plays a really big
role right so
you want to make sure to incorporate
that
one more final announcement
if you want to learn about this no
better way than checking out
intuitivebase.com which is a self-paced
learning course that is going to come
out in a week or two so it's almost done
we're very excited about it
and we're basically if you like this
style of like presenting things in a
more code first intuitive way this is
what we did there because we were all
frustrated with the way that basic
modeling is usually taught
and it's made for
people who like to code the data
scientists and python developers so
if you're one of the slides i'm going to
tweet them
if you have problems where you think
these types of approaches could be
helpful for your business
happy to get an email from you
and we also run corporate workshops so
with that thank you so much for your
time and attention
thanks everyone do does anyone have a
question do you want to ask a question
hi um thanks for the talk first of all i
wanted to ask about the slide you had
where you were including other data
sources
um yeah that one so
because we work on similar problems and
we we include data sources like that are
not directly marketing related so things
like you know the time of year and the
day the month which are not you know
they're not really related to how much
you spend on advertising or like sending
vouchers so
have you kind of looked at the effect of
including those sorts of variables as
well
like weekday effects or
like like what sorry
what type of facts i missed the first
part what data sources do you have so
things like
so because we work on very similar
problems but as input variables we also
include things like the um day of the
year the the week of the year that kind
of thing so yeah yeah so that is
included here as well so seasonality
right like on christmas things are very
different than um yeah so that can be
like explicitly included as well yes
yeah exactly um so yeah the the way
these gaussian processes work they allow
you to include some cyclicality um and
then on top of that
as covariates you can include
like yeah this is like a holiday and
maybe even
a value indicating how significant you
that that is to your time series yeah so
they can all be done thanks
just a quick question yeah so sometimes
i'm getting like a very wide height
posterior density interval you know for
the coefficients and when i use more
informative priors you know it's getting
narrowed down a little bit and it's hard
to define
what exact priors you know to use for
stochastical uh variables so what is
your recommendation for that
for choosing priors yes you know what i
mean when when you choose like
like more informative priors your hdi
interval getting a little bit narrow but
it's hard to define like where to stop
you know this is always the problem i
hit so i try to find the middle
to bring to my team of analytics because
they always ask me oh why your intervals
changing all the time you know i see
yeah
yeah so prize is definitely a very uh
often debated uh topic
usually
we come up from it from two sides one is
well yeah we want to incorporate as much
information as possible
but also we want to use it in a
regularizing way right so
yeah if you run a linear regression
often you would place normal priors
centered around zero because you say
well in the absence of anything i'm just
going to say zero i'm gonna er on the
side of
they're not being effect
which is very similar to what machine
learners have been doing for
ever
and but yeah so prior is uh something
which is totally fine to iteratively
work on and improve so uh yeah the fact
that that you're changing them and
improving them and that the results
change is is not a problem per se so
that just means that your model is
hopefully getting better
but yeah
so
in general the whole bayesian field is
moving towards informative priors and
like we started out with like uniform
price everywhere right and that just
turned out to be a terrible idea um
right yeah um so yeah in
incorporating information is
is critical especially for these complex
models there like if you don't have
informative price there they just won't
even get off the ground yeah
so yeah oh i guess the last point prior
predictive checks is another really cool
thing
i can see you and you anyone else have a
question
okay i'll come here first and then keep
your hands up i'll bring the mic
thank you
so my question was about the likelihood
so use a normal distribution but is
there a way to test or how would you
test this assumption is valid
yeah
so great question
the first thing i would do after i fit
this is to run a posterior predictive
check where simulate new data from the
model and then see how well the model
explains the real data i've seen right
and often that will actually show like
oh this isn't fitting the data at all
maybe because i have some outlier and in
that case i would then say well i'm
going to replace my normal distribution
non-likelihood with a student t
distribution which has
a lot of mass in the tails and is robust
and then i run the posterior predictor
check again and i see like oh now it
nicely fits the data and it's not skewed
by outliers
so just take the last three questions
together so just ask the questions and
then maybe you can summarize
i'm mainly just asking um you treated
the channels mostly independently and
you but you mentioned that sometimes
they they can affect each other and you
can have cannibalization in some cases
and all sorts of stuff is that in some
way taken into account and just
yeah so this was the point on this slide
is that we're
uh that they're changing but they're
actually they're there's a hierarchical
model underneath this so they're all
actually tight they're not independent
they're all tied together via this
global time varying process uh basically
mapping this idea from here that yeah
these things do share similarity so
yeah during covit
like everything would go down and and
this would affect all of them
individually
and
you built some type of
automated budget allocator on top of
this as well that then optimizes uh yeah
i like the way you think yes um exactly
so
this is uh called bayesian decision
making um and so you could just and a
lot of people do is they just take the
sms they run optimize and then they get
some answers
but you
want to include the whole posterior in
this as well right so that you're not
just optimizing for the most likely case
but of course all cases so that way
you're getting way more robust estimates
there's a blog post i wrote about this
um
on bayesian decision making on t wiki
dot io which is my blog so um but yeah
that's exactly where this is going the
next step would be plugging this into an
optimizer to tell me what is the optimal
allocation of my media spend
to do that
and
final question
or i think so
um how is it captured the fact that
spending money today will have an impact
not only on the new users uh
tomorrow or even in the long term how is
that incorporated in the way you you
presented it yeah um
so i showed you this uh dk fun the
situation function there's another
function which is an exponential decay
function
forward where like a marketing thing
does not
just have an effect today but actually
over the next couple of days and then so
that's essentially convolution um and
that is called the uh the ad stock
function so there's two the basic mmm
has yeah the saturation function
and the stock function to model the
effect that you have and that is
included in there i just didn't mention
it
cool thank you so much everyone thank
you
lovely the rest of the day thanks
[Applause]